hi  lucy good morning it's me henry we  are on i think about our 5 000  date together it's been great i want to  catch you up  you have a thing called amnesia and i am  your husband  we have a daughter and she's about  40 now or something like that what i  know it's bananas uh  but i'm not done yet it's 2020  and we're also in the middle of a  pandemic  which is a terrible thing baseball games  are now being played in front of  cardboard people  sounds kind of like you're making this  up oh yes if the  room you're in right now smells uh a bit  like  farts uh that was that was you it does  kind of smell like farts in here are you  sure that wasn't you  oh it doesn't matter either way